i love how they brought [ __ ] toby 2.0
on there
so [ __ ] up yeah yeah what's up i'm
more mature i'm more laid-back and i'm
also a soccer player yeah and i like
your girl yeah
[ __ ] chloe want and winding them up
the that part was really funny but then
also mary in the interview in the
talking head before saying i just hope
he's not a footballer because that was
my last ex-boyfriend and then he comes
in and she's like what are you doing
he's like i'm a footballer and she's
like [ __ ]
she's like
oh you're [ __ ] hot
she's just
already taking out her earrings right
well i sleep in the fifth bed
but yeah sorry chloe wanting no yeah
that was so funny yeah just [ __ ] with
toby that was pretty funny i really want
to get to know him
i'm just winding you up and then toby
like he had like a brief serial killer
moment he was like
winding me up it's not a good idea
you're laughing but i'm not yeah this
[ __ ] up smile
what are you gonna do man i took one
note of him like in wednesday's episode
i think when he was like finally coming
to terms with the fact that he likes
chloe again yeah and he's like
embracing how much that like how much
he's feeling towards her yeah and he
said
hold on
he said i just want to grab her and
hug
but it was really like prime all the way
said yeah i just want to grab her and
hug her dude
it's kind of wild man we're watching the
dude
catch feelings for the first time i know
like in real time never dated anyone in
his life do you when do you think was
the first time you caught feelings like
caught him caught him yeah like uh yeah
um in high school
not earlier you know like elementary
school
um
yeah maybe
no probably like
probably like eighth grade no actually
you're right middle school it was middle
school yeah i got
i could i couldn't stop like looking at
this girl that i had a crush on and so
my teacher
uh his name was
his name was mr zee i think he was like
my favorite teacher
he uh moved me right next to her in the
middle of class in front of everyone
he's like you can't stop looking at her
so i just moved you and i was like you
[ __ ] dude you [ __ ] her
love island yes love island
yeah it's rough
[Music]
cody come talk to me after this lesson
so she told me she likes you so you need
to talk to her during the next lesson
okay that's that's all i'm saying okay
cool yeah so
everyone this is the numerator
we got the cody
more talking please thank you
i was just staring that's all i was
doing you were just looking at her and
we were like sitting across the
classroom from each other so i was just
like i couldn't like i had a crush on
her so i was like
dude she's so hot
so what happened after z was like all
right dude
you like
dude this this is so [ __ ] up thinking
back to this it's hilarious it's
hilarious yeah
like what the [ __ ] was i doing like
probably how can you make like how do
you make it that obvious where the
teacher is like this is a disruption to
the class how old are you
probably like
i don't know 12. so you were playing
middle school yeah like something like
that yeah like like sixth grade you're
thinking like 9 10 yeah maybe 11. you
were not discreet probably it was you
probably weren't looking down as much as
you were looking up yeah that dude was
probably talking and everyone had their
head down on the paper i was like
yo
so whatever every time she kind of looks
up and makes eye contact
[Laughter]
what happened after uh you moved
the clash just laughed at me
and then
not i had to sit there next to her the
rest of the red face
for the rest of the class at least and
then the next one i think we switched
around again but did you ever close
oh yeah you closed yeah
you got no i think we kissed you got her
instant message i think we like actually
technically i think we dated for a
little bit but like didn't do anything
because you know we're
yeah
children 10. yeah
like i got to say that she was my
girlfriend i'm pretty sure
this is like the dead opposite oh i just
tore my laptop here real quick rear
meniscus oh that's yeah this is the uh
the bar they had to put in there
they put that in there when i was uh
dead popped out of my spine yeah i was
dead lifting 17 000 pounds yeah then to
put that to reinforce my spine 30 of our
bodies are actually metal rods that's
why we got this big
this is the dead opposite of that story
but
when i was in uh preschool there's this
little girl
uh i'll never forget this terror
uh she's a little blonde girl her name
was danielle
and she decided i was the one okay
but the way she decided was not cute it
was like screaming like a banshee and
running after me and like just bullying
yeah yeah sick and so
it started like
it was kind of like you know
i was just like meat like she's just
like that's the one and she'd kind of
like be loud about it like i want that
one and i'm like okay and so i remember
that it was like this weird dynamic
where i was like forcing myself to make
friend groups to like hide from her okay
i remember just like sheer anxiety
because i've never been encountered with
a [ __ ]
kid let alone like a girl like that it
was just like two things at the same
time
and
i just remember her terrorizing most of
my preschool experience
so and then at their points where i
would see her in public and i would like
just melt down inside i'm like this
[ __ ] is i don't know what i thought was
gonna happen
but she scared the [ __ ] out of me
she's a man eater
straight up
yeah i i just i didn't that's chloe
that's the young chloe yeah that's just
yeah basically knows what she wants
she's going to go after her yeah yeah
yeah i'd give it to me now yeah yeah
[Laughter]
that's hilarious
oh yeah it did what was uh
what was your middle school crush's name
what was her name i'm not gonna
air that out right now
who's gonna know what
i mean i'm still like sort of friends
with her oh rip like then we went to
high school together well for the first
couple years
we still see each other every every now
and then but she's like married or
something i don't know
sick
yeah you should tell her husband the
story absolutely appreciated
i kissed your girl in sixth grade bro i
could not stop staring at your girl
like way back when it was like 20 years
ago
oh you're her husband sick
yeah i kissed her first
it's cool man
whoa
eating my leftovers what's up man
sloppy seconds what's up boy
this guy loves a sloppy joe let me tell
you
how's it taste bro
how's it taste for real
this episode has gone completely off the
rails
what are we even talking about you know
i mean love island right yeah right
right well i think we hit it all i mean
i don't know what no we got it all for
sure um
so
what's next addictions
so there's going to be definitely one
more recoupling ray coupling yes i think
that teddy and that
new robot girl i think that's going to
happen i think it might happen too i
don't think that fantasy thing is going
to i think he's probably like nah
yeah you know and i think the new
footballer will get with mary but i
think they're gonna get voted out yeah i
don't think they just have like a strong
it's just like whenever you come from
castlemore
like matt's lucky to have gotten this
far yeah yeah i feel like most people
from castlemore don't stick around yeah
so i think they're probably out dale got
ousted yeah dale dale you're right he is
conor mcgregor i didn't see it before
but now it's totally someone was like
that i was like jesus christ someone's
like does noel think
conor mcgregor invented tattoos i'm like
it's not the tattoos it's the face it's
the same face structure yeah
that same crazy ass like
uh
denture smile just
yeah so
yeah predictions uh that's it
i think fate
the fact that faye didn't get voted out
is nuts to me i know
so
i couldn't believe jake was bottom three
but i get it yeah i get it because
he's a snake yeah but i was surprised
that it's normally like you said it's
new people mm-hmm people that the
audience doesn't don't know as well so
yeah like you know
who cares yeah
that's how bad his [ __ ] was
the fact that that would be worse to
people than what faye did come on yeah
come on man yeah
so yeah who's gonna win it all
you think liam and millie
i think
toby and chloe man
really i think they'll win it no i think
it's going to be not because liam for
she
i think the two of them chloe and toby
are
much more like
lovable yeah and you and everyone
appreciates
like toby's just like man like you just
shake your head you're like [ __ ] toby
yeah but like people love him like he's
you know he's almost like a labrador
like
how you dumb dog like whatever it is
pretty funny his his like arc that he's
taken yeah where he was like such a
[ __ ] idiot [ __ ] boy didn't know what
he wanted and now he's like
yeah just full he's like my hands are in
this girl's heart yeah she can do
whatever she wants you could crush me
when he said that damn yeah
that's what i mean yeah and and i think
chloe's like a real genuine person yeah
so
uh
i i think they're a better story than
liam and millie cause liam is just
groveling because he got caught yeah and
he's just you know he's still like a
horny [ __ ] at the end of the day yeah
he's a horn he's you know what he is a
filthy boy oh yeah he's a filthy boy oh
yes
oh you're sucking diesel sucking
diesel what a phrase it
oh you went out to the lash last night
and we were sucking diesel diesel it was
a whale of a night